hey guys our world
is changing fast more and more guys are
growing up
without a good father at home
it's terrible we are becoming a
fatherless
society some guys have never even
met their fathers and some wish
that their father would care enough to
spend time with them
quality time and then there are some
that wish
they never even had a father because of
the way that they behave
drunk all the time abusive
lazy and the list just goes on but in
this video i want to talk to you
and i want to tell you five important
things that every guy
out there without the father should know
and understand
this might be the most important video
that you will watch
of your life let's get to it
i have a dream that's all i need
i've made mistakes but mistakes make you
strong
now just before i get into the five
things you need to know
that if you grow up without a father it
might influence you
negatively if you don't know how to deal
with it correctly
they did an enormous amount of studies
on this
and today we know that kids who grow up
without a father
in a home may experience diminished
self-concept
behavioral problems poor academic
performance
violent crime teen pregnancy drug and
alcohol abuse
homelessness 90 of kids who run away
have an absent father experience
emotional abuse physical health problems
mental health problems and bad
relationships
you can also check this out at
psychology today
but you need to know that it doesn't
mean that all of these things will
happen to you
some of these things are just more
likely to happen
but you know what underdogs make the
best
types of life stories and you can choose
to make a success out of your life by
dealing with all the issues
and moving forward by making the right
choices
and to help you do it i'm gonna go
through five important things that you
need to
know and understand let's start with the
first one
your father does not have to be your
father
figure there are good men out there
strong confident humble and successful
men
that you can learn from if your father
cannot really be a good father figure
then look for a good father figure in
someone else
there are many good role models out
there that leave
a legacy behind and all the lessons
life lessons they learned in books or
videos and then
choose the right type of friends good
quality friends that will help you to
become not just a good man but a great
man
you are not your father your genes
does not just come from your dad but
from thousands of people before him
in the family tree and guess what you
are not one of them
you are your own person you are unique
you have your own story to live your own
journey
and no one can do it for you you are not
your father and you are not your past
if you have a father who is not a great
dad
you need to remember he is the way he is
probably because he never dealt with his
own issues
and he doesn't know how to but you are
different
you still have your whole life in front
of you you need to be hungry you need to
be starving
to be better this deep drive
desire deep within you to be the best
that you can be don't compare yourself
to other people
not to your father and not to other
people your father is not your
competition
your friends are not your competition
other people are not
your competition or your enemy and you
don't need to try to be
better or try to beat them you
are your own worst enemy
and you need to fight yourself to
achieve
success be the best that you can be
every single day of your life
you will fail many times in this life
but failure itself does not make
you a failure
you know i had a dad who was not always
perfect
in fact there's no such thing as a
perfect father because no one is perfect
i'm not perfect and you're not perfect
but one of the things that i learned
from my dad
is to never give up never stay down
he made many mistakes but he always got
up he stood up like a man
he owned it and then he tried again and
again
and again until he was successful
believe me
you will make many mistakes in this life
there's no question about it
bill gates was a harvard dropout and
watched his first company
traffic data crumble and fall to pieces
steve job was fired by his own company
at 30.
albert einstein could not even speak
fluently until the age of nine
and he was expelled from school steven
spielberg the great movie director
had poor grades in high school and was
rejected by the university of southern
california
three times let me give you a quote from
michael jordan the famous basketball
player
i've missed more than 9 000 shots in my
career
i've lost almost 300 games 26 times i've
been trusted
to take the game winning shot and missed
i failed over and over again in my life
and that's why i succeed
failure has the power to make you very
strong but only if you own your mistakes
and learn from it
don't always blame yourself it's not
your fault
that you don't have a dad or that he is
never around
or that he drinks is not your
fault sometimes life is unfair
and you can't always control everything
but you can always control how you think
about it
and how you react to it and apart from
that
if you fail at something it doesn't mean
that it's always your fault
whenever something happens there's
always
hundreds thousands of other factors
involved
in every action and sometimes an
opportunity will just close
but you know when one door closes
another one usually
opens up just be patient for it
and when it opens up go for it
know what a real man is a real man is
not selfish
does not make excuses does not run from
his responsibilities
he does not hit a woman and he's never
arrogant or boastful
real man is humble honest open-minded
stands up for what he believes in he
treats other people with respect
he works hard he builds up those around
him he takes care of his family
physically and emotionally he has
self-control
and pursues truth justice and integrity
what kind of man are you and what kind
of man
do you want to be the choice was
is and will always be yours